The fifth and final issue in basics about evolutionary thinking as they pertain
to evolutionary medicine is that there are quite different styles of thought and
in particular in this area,
we can think typologically,
we can think of the population level or we can think about evolutionary trees
and the way that one is thinking makes quite a difference to the analysis of the
problem.
Yeah,
so in general,
in understanding arguments,
we need to ask what are the implicit assumptions that are being made?
What different meanings are people assigning the words?
What issues are hanging unexpressed in the background and in brief are people
coming from?
Yeah.
Let's start with typological thinking.
If one is thinking typologically,
then the most important thing to know about something is the category that it
represents.
That is the quote normal condition.
Okay.
This way of looking at the world derives from Plato's theory of ideals and
Aristotle's theory of types.
The type embodies the essence of the thing,
and scientific examples include the hydrogen atom,
the vertebrate kidney,
the eukaryotic ribosome.
In other words,
if you've seen one,
you've seen them all.
Okay?
It's actually quite useful
whenever the average properties of a thing are much more important than its
variation.
Yeah.
That's sometimes the case in molecular biology and cell biology and physiology,
but but not always.
It is a powerful simply simplification that makes life a lot easier.
So the importance of thing about type of logical thinking is to know when can
you get away with it.
It will mislead you when you are thinking about evolution or about the adaptive
immune system or about many other things.
It is useful in cell and molecular biology.
It is useful to have a concept of an animal cell as we have here on the left
that has a certain structure.
It has a cell membrane,
it has a nucleus,
it has cytoplasm,
it has endoplasmic reticulum,
it has mitochondria and so forth.
It is useful to think of the Ribas ohm is having a certain structure and
performing a certain function in protein synthesis.
And that is an example where it probably is a good idea to think typologically
on the other hand,
population thinking is the most important,
uh,
type of thinking in evolutionary biology.
And when you're that,
then the most important thing to know about it is the variation in the
population from which the trait is drawn.
That is tied to Darwin's insight into the central role of variation and natural
selection
examples,
gene frequencies,
relative risk of heart disease,
stratified by sex or lifestyle or all of the recent developments leading to
personalized medicine.
So this way of looking at the world emphasizes variation in the population and
in the processes that change it with individuals,
seen his samples,
whose traits can be estimated from population frequencies.
Population thinking is useful whenever it is important to know whether and how
fast something will evolve.
That includes antibiotic resistance,
pathogen,
virulence,
cancer,
malignancy,
and anything related to the Microbiota.
Yeah,
population thinking forces us into conceptualizing frequency distributions,
patterns of variation and space and time and probabilities rather than
certainties.
Yeah.
Here's an example.
Here's a very interesting case of antibiotic resistance analyzed recently,
uh,
in Cambridge,
Massachusetts,
there were Gut microbiome isolates taken from two humans.
The differed in percentage of isolates that are resistant to single and multiple
antibiotics.
So one human here is in red.
The other humanism blue,
the samples from the humans are these,
every vertical line is a particular kind of bacterium.
Every horizontal row is a particular kind of antibiotic,
and the intensity shows how well that particular bacterium is growing in the
presence of that particular antibiotic.
And what you can see is that the two humans differ.
So there is variation in the human population in their microbiota.
You can see the bat that the bacteria found in those two humans also differ in
their ability to grow in the presence of antibiotics.
The most striking thing about this is that neither of these two humans had been
using antibiotics recently,
and nevertheless,
they each contained hundreds of different bacteria that were resistant to
multiple antibiotics.
Yeah.
Now what about cancer?
Every individual cancer is a process of clonal evolution and you can see clones
here in different colors,
and the idea is that selection is applied to the clones.
They are competing with each other for local resources,
nutrients,
oxygen,
space,
things like that.
At some point,
a particular clone acquires the ability to move and invade other tissue.
That is this line here leading to some metasticies.
Then TX means therapy.
Chemotherapy is being applied.
One of the metastatic clones manages to survive and that then leads to the
recurrence of the cancer because this one is resistant to that type of
chemotherapy.
So we think about a cancer as being a genetically heterogeneous set of clones.
So as a population
it's a population of clones and they deliver,
they differ in their history of mutations.
Selection is allowing some of them to expand and some of them eventually to
escape from chemotherapy.
The ecosystems they occupy,
our different tissues to which clones can become locally adapted.
And this way of looking at cancer as a micro evolutionary process shows us that
one of the reasons for the recurrence of cancers after chemotherapy is the
genetic heterogeneity of the clones that that therapy is operating on.
Okay.
What about tree thinking?
If one is engaging in tree thinking,
then the most important thing to know about something,
it's where does it sit on a phylogenetic tree?
Yeah.
This derives from the insight that all species are related in a single tree of
life.
They're not independent replicates within a larger class,
but they're connected within a phylogenetic tree.
What basically that means is that many of the properties of descendants are
inherited from ancestors
that emphasizes explanations within the context of phylogenetic trees in which
differences arise by deviation from the last common ancestor.
It's useful whenever there's an insight to be drawn from comparisons among
species and in evolutionary medicine.
Such comparisons suggest the insights that include the Association of Invasive
Placentas with metastatic cancer,
the Association of Upright posture with problems of childbirth.
Why whales and elephants do not all die of colon cancer as teenagers.
Pedro's paradox,
why African green monkeys have Siv but they don't progress to aids and why heart
disease presents differently in chimpanzees.
So knowing the phylogenetic context of a particular disease or trait can often
give us quite a bit of comparative insight into its origin and therefore
possibly into its causes.
Knowing where on the tree of life and condition is present or absent immediately
gives us clues to its correlates and causes.
Let's do some tree thinking about birth.
What we have here in the picture are diagrams of the birth canals,
of mechanics,
of givens,
of Orangutans,
chimpanzees,
gorillas and humans.
And the thing that strikes you if you're just looking at the upper part of the
picture,
is that the head of the infant being born in a mechanic is completely filling
the birth canal.
And so is the head of a human infant completely filling the birth canal weather.
Whereas it looks as though birth is much easier and orangutans,
chimpanzees and gorillas.
Now,
what is the primitive and what is the derived state here?
Is it really that the human birth canal is filled by the head of the human
infant because humans are similar to mechanics or is it some other comparisons?
It's more appropriate.
Well,
if we look at the phylogenetic tree than we see immediately that the key
comparison isn't between mechanics in humans is between chimpanzees and humans.
And that tells us that the difficulties encountered in human childbirth are a
fairly recent derived condition that must be associated with something that
changed between chimpanzees and humans.
And we will go into that later in the course.
Now,
what about cancer?
In this case,
what you see is a phylogenetic tree.
It starts here with a normal cell goes to initiated to herself with the
mutation.
There is then a process of some clonal selection and then there are some
phylogenetic branches which lead into metasticies that colonize lung or liver.
They can be genotyped and the tree can be reconstructed and that gives us real
estimates of relationship in age.
What it tells us is that in this case,
these cases of pancreatic cancer,
the cancer's originated about 18 years before they were detected.
We use a molecular clock to estimate the time between the initiative to herself
and the death of the patient and the harvest and metastasis.
Now knowing that gives us new ideas for methods of detection that could prevent
growth and spread of pancreatic cancer.
So tree thinking is useful in the clinic in understanding how the history of a
particular cancer develops.
So to summarize,
people think about problems in profoundly different ways.
It's important to match the way that you think to the problem that you're trying
to solve.
Population and tree thinking,
our standard and evolutionary biology.
They emphasize the importance of variation in populations of frequencies,
probabilities,
history,
and comparisons.